Hello
, this is Smith, who lives next door. Do you
know trick or treat?
I
'm sorry, my
kids are coming here.
What time exactly are they coming?
I don't know the exact time, but I'm
going to
visit the whole
neighborhood?  I understand that you want your children
to
experience the events Mr. Smith experienced in his home country, the United States, starting with
Halloween
.
I prepared a little by
myself.I
would appreciate it if you could give me this.How many pieces should I give
?
I've heard that there are many people in Japan who like cosplay,
but it's true
.
I thought it would be an absolute nuisance, so I tried preparing this one too,
but it's a boring one, but
if you don't mind, I'd like Tokyo macaroons.